[Music]
hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we're gonna be
going over the sicilian defence for
black and it starts out pawn to e4 and
black responds pawn to c5 now this is
actually the most common defense for
black to the e4 opening for white and
it's actually the best scoring and most
statistics actually prefer d4 as an
opening for a white on the first move
only because of how well the Sicilian
defense plays against e4 even the top
level play this is going to be the most
widely used defense for black and so you
definitely want to know for your own
game how to play it and some of the key
concepts that you should always keep in
the back of your mind when you are
playing it so we're gonna go ahead and
look at a few of the lines future videos
we'll go a little more in-depth into the
different variations that you can get
into from the main line but today we're
gonna kind of touch on the key points of
the opening and how it looks so white
usually continues
Knight to f3 basically trying to gain
control of the e5 and the d4 square
obviously at the beginning of the game
both sides are trying to gain sinner
control black is taking away this d4
thrust that white would eventually like
to to play black now is going to respond
with pawn to d6 now this does a couple
things first thing it does it does
protect his pawn on c5 and the second
thing he does white eventually would
like to continue just moving up his pawn
down the food chain to pawn to e5 and so
this is stopping that attack so very
good movies got a nice little pawn
structure keep in mind though that his
Bishop on f8 is not going anywhere
anytime soon he is blocked by three
pawns eventually though you're going to
want to move this pawn I'm either to e6
or a5 you're eventually going to want to
get your Bishop to e7 unless you play
the dragon and you can cheto once your
Bishop is on e7 you can then castle once
the knight is developed and you will
have very good development on the King
side so that's how eventually you're
going to play with this Bishop your
Bishop here on the c8 square you're
eventually going to want to thrust this
pawn on the B file and you're gonna want
to get the Bishop on this long diagonal
aimed right at the Kings side so few key
concepts to look at at the very
beginning we're gonna go continue
forward with the mainline white thrust
for trying to gain center control with
pawn to d4 and black here is just going
to
sure this with pawn takes d4 obviously
black wants to take away Center control
white now has two options he can take
with the knight take with the queen
obviously you don't want to take with
the Queen early on with white just
because you don't want to get your queen
involved too early and if you do take
black can always develop his knight here
with c6 and black will have to retreat
his queen losing a tempo so more than
likely you will see Knight captures d4
again these moves that I'm saying should
not be done if they are done by your
opponent you should definitely take
advantage of those moves and exploit
your your mistakes by your opponents
so from here black usually continues
with Knight to f6 basically putting
pressure on this
efore square trying to put more pressure
on the center black or excuse me white
now has to respond to defend this the
best way to do that is the main line
which is just simply Knight to c3 and
now there are three very good variations
that we're going to touch on and later
videos we will go a little more in-depth
the first one is the NASS tour which is
just pawn to a6 and this is actually a
very aggressive move white can no longer
come with his bishop and attack the the
King
eventually you can thrust forward with
this pawn to
b5 it has a defender from the a6 square
your Bishop can come on this long
diagonal attack so at the outset it
doesn't look like it does much but as
the game goes forward it's going to be a
very good move as you try to attack the
King side the second move that we're
going to look at is simply the classical
variation which is just a development of
the knight here to c6 white can always
capture here and then black can take on
c6 and begin to thrust forward again for
center control so that is the classical
and then last we have the dragon a lot
of times you will see people try to
fianchetto on the King side they'll
bring their Bishop to g7 Castle kingside
and build up a defense that way so a lot
of different variations that you can do
it this is a very good defense it's a
very attacking defense you can get a lot
of good play from it so those are some
of the key concepts to keep in mind
later videos we will go into some of the
other variations thanks again for
watching hope you enjoyed hope you've
learned a lot definitely check out the
other videos check out the website and
be sure to subscribe so you know when
new videos are coming out thanks for
watching